Hey Coders,  welcome to the daily program of our YouTube series where we solve different problems
which are posted on the subreddit, "daily programmer".
In this particular video, we're going to talk about a problem called "Condensing Sentences",  which is number 319 on the subreddit.
And, first off, before we start talking about the problem, make sure you spend time yourself solving on paper
and implementing it in Javascript, so that you really practice by yourself how to problem solve.
Otherwise, let's go ahead and break it down on the whiteboard.
All right, so the condensing sentences problem is like so. If you're given a string, for instance, we have a string here that says "no one ever runs so often"
what we want to do is condense the words together
So if there's any overlap, so, in this case we have "o",
so, the "o's"overlap. We should combine them together into one word.
Then again if this one will overlap with the next one we need to combine it with the next word
Or "r" overlaps here
"S" overlaps with that and then "often" again, it's another overlap
So in this case we're going to convert this entire sentence into one combined string.
Now another example we can do is "live verses", which is going to be condensed into:
"l-i-v-e-r-s-e-s"
so notice that there's two here that overlap
And then we only use that once
So then if we have a string such as "hello world", this would have no condensing
happening to it because the beginning of the right word does not have anything that matches at the end of the left word
So now that we talked about the problem, and how it's actually defined,
how would we actually solve this on paper, right? So if we have another word...so let's go and
Put the string again "live verses". If we wanted to check if two words in this case
I'll say this is the left word and this is the right word
If I want to check if the left word and the right word should be combined
What I can do is just continuously look through the left word and shorten the word that I'm looking for from the starting point
so for instance I can say
Does live or live
exists at the beginning of the right word?
If not, check the next one. Does "ive" exists in the beginning of the right word?
And in this case, it doesn't, so then again, check if "ve" begins any of the right word; and it does.
So in this case, we know we can condense these words together, and we can do so.
Continue on to the next words in the string.
So there's two main sub problems that you can solve in order to solve the major problem. This first one is given two strings
Can you condense them together and if so, how do you condense them together, right?
and we just show that used continuously create sub strings by knocking off the first character the left and
Checking if it exists at the start of the right all right. So for solving the second sub problem assume
We have a longer string. How do we make sure we loop over every word and condense where possible all right?
So one thing you can do is first we can break this apart by spaces, right?
And convert it into some type of an array or list, so instead of being an actual string we can instead
just say that we have an internal array
with our four words in it.
And over here, we have the different indexes of that array.
So the first step to do was to take the left word so let's say left, and I'll say right
and check if they can be condensed. And if they can be condensed, what you want to do is combine them together
and overwrite this slot in the array with the condensed word.
So remember the array of Index 0 we
put the condensed word into,
and then the Index 1 word we can just go ahead and remove because we already combined it with the previous one.
And if you remove something from array remember that the indices get updated.
So then we can continue to do the same thing
And since we just found and condensed a word let's keep this on the same so left
But now we're just checking a new right word
So can these two be condensed?
No, they cannot so at this point what we can continuously do is just change the left and the right or increment or loop
so now we have this as our left word and
This as a right word
and
Then again that we cannot combine these or condense these together so at this point
We've reached the end of the array so we can go ahead and break out of the the loop so at this point
You should have a good understanding of how to do this on a whiteboard or on paper
So let's try to convert it and implement it in Javascript, so like we mentioned before there's two sub problems
You can solve in order to solve the overall
Top level problem
So the first sub problem is how do you condense two words together and find out if they should be condensed at all.
so to start off. Let's write a function called Condense
words and it takes two parameters a left and
a right
Which is a left word and the right word and then that's going to return null if they can't condense the words
Otherwise it's going to return the two words condensed together
So starting off remember that algorithm
We did where we have to loop through each substring and kind of chunk offs at the first letter of the left word?
So to do that. We can go ahead and loop through
the length of the Left word
And we can say left substring is equal to left dot
substring of that i
which will go ahead and say give us all the characters
And then give us all the characters starting index 1 give us all the characters starting Index 2
Until we get to the very last character
And once we have the left substring we can check to say does the right start with
Thing is actually called startswith, so does right.startswith(left.substring)
And if it does let's just go ahead and return that condensed word which is going to be left plus the right and then replace
that left substring with an empty string and
Then up here and secure the extra space
And then we can go ahead and try to test it out to make sure it works as expected
So I'll do console dot log, and I'll pass it live and I'll pass it verses. And
again an example this should print out one word combined together, so if I were to run this
We see that it does print out
The two words combined so that we've written our first
Subproblem to Condense two words together and that we've tested out to make sure it works
Let's also test that with hello world and verify that it returns null
And it does so again. This is a good example of how you solve a
Top-level problem by breaking it into subproblems and testing it as you develop it so now we know this one's good
So let's work on the other sub problem, which will be
Condensed
sentence
which will take a string and again what we need to do is loop over that string for each word and
Like we saw an example on the whiteboard we need to split it first so we can say let words, actually I'll do
const words is equal to string dot split
like the type
And we're going to split it on the empty characters alright, so that'll give us all the words split up
And then finally we want to return
Those same words, but join together
So then the meat and potatoes of this method is we need to loop over every word one by one so we'll say let, oh sorry, we'll say
Before let I is equal to zero I less than words dot length
minus one and then increment I and
That's because we don't want to actually reach the end of the string and go out of bounds
so we stop I one before the end and
Then again, we have the left and the right so we can say const left is equal to words of I
Const right is equal to words of I plus 1 and then we need to call Condense words, so we'll say const
Condense
Is equal to condense words left and right?
if
Condense is actually defined therefore. We could have condensed the words together we need to go ahead and overwrite
the first word
with the condensed word
Go ahead and rename this to
Condensed
and
Then we need to remove
Index plus one or I plus one so we can say words that Splice I
Plus 1 and then length of 1 which will just remove the next word since we combined it with the previous one
And then finally we need to continuously check the same word that we've condensed over and over again to see if it can be
combined with the 1 after so we can say i minus minus
To kind of prevent it from doing this increment up here so at this point. We can kind of go up here
In fact let's before we do this. Let's make this a little bit easier, so
Just so we have less variables to mess around with we can say there condense equals condense words
Words I or it's I plus 1
So now at this point. We can change from Condense words to condense sentence, and then we can change this to
um like one of those long sentences we had before which I just copy this in here
No one ever runs, so often if we run this
See that it prints out all the words combined together or condensed together
I also have a couple of other ones on my clipboard we can kind of try out so cut and paste those in
So we see no one has ever run so often gets combined
The one yellow low dog gets combined to yellow dog the Black Kettle is hot
We combine black and kettle together so it's going to condensed and of course hello world does not get condensed at all.
So that about wraps up how you solve this  condensed sentences
problem number three one nine on the daily program or subreddit
If you have any questions feel free to ask them in the comments below or if you have a different implementation
Feel free to post your jSBin or whatever link that you want and maybe we can have a discussion about other ways to solve this
I saw one solution which uses Regex to solve this which is like one line of code
But I feel like as a beginner programmer. You should probably learn how to
Manually solve things before you just resort to using Regex although Regex is pretty elegant. Again if you liked the video
Feel free to give us a thumbs up and then also subscribe to the free code Camp channel below alright. Thanks for watching